écoutez effectivement c on en revient
toujours à cette séparation et à cette
sensibilité différente en fonction des
ménages hausse de prix ce qui est
intéressant est ce qu'on voit
aujourd'hui c'est que quelque part les
gouvernements européens ont compris que
les ménages les plus modestes vont être
très fortement pénalisées il ya des
mesures qui ont été prises en italie il
ya des mesures qui ont été prises en
espagne en france il ya eu le fameux le
fameux le fameux chèque inflation et
donc on sent bien que c'est un sujet
aussi qui socialement et difficile on a
parlé d' inflation perçue par rapport à
l'inflation réelle et donc tout ça fait
que aujourd'hui c'est on se retrouve
devant une situation où vous avez le
réel où effectivement hormis l'énergie
on a plutôt des prix qui sont
relativement stables et quand on dit du
coup les prix sont relativement stables
il faut savoir que l'inflation de
service et voilà tout ce qui est tout ce
qui est service c'est autour de 1 2%
les trois-quarts de l'impôt en france
sont des services donc comment voulez
vous que votre employeur qui va gagner
un ou deux et demi pour cent de plus sur
son chiffre d'affaires puisse vous
rémunérez nettement mieux donc les
conditions pour que pour qu'il y ait
cette fameuse boucle prix salaires ne
sont pas réunies et actuellement on a
une phase transitoire avec les prix de
l'énergie qui qui explose il faut
espérer on verra si les marchands raison
que les prix se calment mais si ce n'est
pas le cas la question se posera de
comment est ce qu'on fait pour garder
cette situation soutenable pour les
ménages les plus modestes les gens qui
ont besoin de prendre leur voiture pour
aller travailler les gens qui
aujourd'hui ne nous ne pourrons
peut-être pas se chauffer et c'est donc
il ya il ya véritablement une question
aussi un enjeu social derrière
des recettes cette question c'est qu'ils
sont d'inflation il ya aussi cette
question de l'accès au logement parce
qu'effectivement vous disiez on imprime
de la monnaie on voit pas d'inflation
puis on la voit pas dans l'indicé de
l'insee en revanche parler des marchés
financiers là on en voit une d'inflation
[Musique]